Десь скажуть, що лікарі та медики звикли до таких втрат, але, повірте, це дуже складно,
коли ти не можеш надати допомогу, коли практично на знімку немає легенів
і ти розумієш, що втрачаєш цю людину, і коли стоять її рідні і кажуть: "Робіть все, що можете".
Кожну втрату переносимо дуже тяжко. Повірте, що це не проходить безслідно.
Я - Мацюк Галина Василівна, мені 55 років. Я працюю лікарем-інфекціоністом в Яремчанській міській лікарні та завідую поліклінікою.
Такого спалаху в нас ще не було. Це є наша перша хвиля така.
У нас бували випадки, коли екстрена медична допомога доставляє пацієнта, а ми кажемо: "Немає місця".
У нас були такі випадки, що хворого із нашого регіону повезли у Винники Львівської області.
Ви можете собі уявити, скільки швидка везла хворого? І в Косів, і в Бурштин...
Таке масове надходження людей ми спостерігали з кінця січня і протягом цілого лютого.
Спочатку поступали люди не з нашого регіону. Це була сусідня Делятинська ОТГ, гірські райони, такі як Чорний Потік, Ослави.
Там масово поступали, там практично в кожному будинку були хворі на коронавірус.
Знову ж таки, ми це пов'язували з тим, що в тих селах багато людей працює за кордоном. І на Новий рік, на Різдво вони приїхали додому.
Під час Різдва, під час Коляди багато спілкувалися.
Зараз з тих сіл уже не поступає до нас людей, натомість є наша зона курортна - Яремче, Микуличі, Яблуниця, з Ворохти поступають.
Було багато туристів, ми не заперечуємо це. Знаєте, основне джерело доходу наших жителів, нашого регіону це є туризм.
Тому наші жителі і садиби мають приватні, які приймають гостей. Можливо, десь воно з цим зв'язано.
Турист, який приїжджає на Буковель, він не тільки катається на лижах. Він їздить подивитися навколишні краєвиди.
Він приїжджає в Яремче, вони відвідують знову ж таки наші торгові точки, вони ходять на сувенірні ринки.
Але основна причина це є недотримання оцих карантинних обмежень.
Я це завжди казала і буду казати. Навіть елементарне носіння масочки, уникання скупчення людей.
Оце є важливо. Без необхідності нема чого старшій людині, яка, скажімо, має супутні патології, відвідувати навіть ті самі ринки чи магазини.
Ми з ковідом працюємо з жовтня місяця. Якщо одним словом, він став більш агресивний.
Важче протікає. Довше протікає. Інакші симптоми є протікання хвороби -  нові, які ми не спостерігали, коли лікували ковід у грудні, у жовтні.
Дуже важкі пневмонії у людей. Це є кровохаркання, це є виражена загальна слабкість, і ураження інших органів і систем -
серцево-судинної, сечовидільної, периферичної нервової системи.
Навіть маємо після лікування той так званий пост-ковідний синдром, який ще набагато важче лікувати, ніж сам ковід.
Люди психологічно важко від цього відходять, дуже важко.
Страшно. Це така хвороба, з якою не можна жартувати, з якою треба спілкуватися на "Ви".
Бо не знаєш, як вона себе поведе. Розумієте? І ми бачимо, що це як лотерея: ти її виграв і видужав - і все добре. А буває, що і ні...
Останнім часом ми понесли такі втрати, де досить молоді люди працездатного віку, які не хворіли ніколи,
які не мали супутніх хронічних захворювань, не запущені.
Я особисто захворіла і передала своєму чоловіку - він також лікар. І він переніс не дуже, скажімо, легку форму. Був у реанімації декілька днів.
Дякувати Богу, все закінчилося благополучно.
Знаєте, психологічно це важко, коли ти розумієш, що приніс додому цю інфекцію.
Так наші колеги, напевно, всі йдуть додому і розуміють, що у них є старі батьки, що у них є діти...
Ми складали списки. Хто виявляв бажання, всі щепилися перший раз.
І не було ніяких важких ускладнень. Всі потемпературили, всі десь мали якісь реакції, але нічого страшного не було.
На працездатність це не вплинуло, люди вийшли на наступний день до роботи.
Ми не знаємо цієї хвороби. Ми рік її вивчаємо, рік за нею спостерігаємо. Бачите, з'являються нові штами. Хвороба себе веде по-інакшому.
Є доказова база - коли 80% людей перехворіє, тоді буде колективний імунітет і люди перестануть так розносити цю інфекцію.
Або є ще один захист - це також доказано, це є світова практика. Це -  вакцинація.
Тому нам від цього ніде не дітися. Ми мусимо вакцинуватися, мусимо цей вірус локалізувати, знешкодити.
У нас така ситуація колись і з грипом була, але потім зрозуміли, що треба вакцинуватися.
Колеги бачать, що не хворіють, або, якщо хворіють, то в легшій формі.
Все нове - все страшне, незвідане. Але нічого страшного немає.